I've been called many names because of  my work of course one of them sounds  like witch but begins with B so I'm  known as the biggest bewitch in Britain  and I'm the most banned woman on the  planet as well I am banned from normal  things like Twitter or PayPal or my own  bank account I'm also banned from um all  British and U.S media apart from you  guys who are Independents I'm banned  from the entire country of South Africa  for highlighting the slaughter of white  Farmers by the ANC band me and I've just  been banned and deported from Australia  for speaker gaps against the tyranny of  lockdown locking down to an island of  people for two years and I'm also banned  from a small place in Great Britain  called Wales but that's fine because  nobody wants to go to Wales because  everybody there is ginger or short and  that's who I am